Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家分享一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are looking at something called cancel culture. That
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨一个叫做“取消文化”的话题。这
is the fear of speaking out, speaking truly in whatever situation you find yourself in for fear of what the repercussions would be. This is such an important episode and it crops up personally, professionally, and in all kinds of dynamics. I am joined by a return guest, Dr. Deborah Kingston, and she is as compassionate and thoughtful and wonderfully inspiring as ever. Hope you find it so useful. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist.
是指在任何情况下，因为害怕后果而不敢发声、不敢说真话的恐惧。这是一个非常重要的话题，它出现在个人生活、职业生涯以及各种人际互动中。今天我的嘉宾是再次回归的黛博拉·金斯顿博士（Dr. Deborah Kingston），她一如既往地富有同情心、思想深刻且令人鼓舞。希望你能从中受益。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。有这个播客陪伴，你将走上获得从业资格的道路。这里是《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。你好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。
Now this episode is going to be available from Christmas Day 2023 and so there will be the occasional reference to the word Christmas, but this is an episode which is good for all year round. So it won't be advertised as a Christmas episode, but it's such an important episode and it runs through the veins of so much of what we do in our roles in mental health but also as we might be trying to you know be the voice of reason in situations or having perhaps very different viewpoints on a variety of topics though actually sometimes it can feel like it's our duty to kind of balance or address. But that can lead to, you know, potential conflict, fallouts.
这期节目将于2023年圣诞节当天发布，因此偶尔会提到“圣诞节”这个词，但这期节目的内容全年适用。所以它不会被宣传为一期圣诞特辑，但它确实非常重要，贯穿了我们在心理健康领域工作的大部分内容，也涉及我们在试图成为某种情况下的理性之声，或者在各种话题上持有非常不同的观点时所面临的挑战。虽然有时我们觉得有责任去平衡或解决这些问题，但这可能会导致潜在的冲突和决裂。
And that's why I wanted to invite our guest back today, who we met previously on the podcast talking about trauma and ADHD and dyslexia. And it's Dr. Deborah Kingston. So I hope you'll find this episode really useful I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side just want to welcome back to the podcast Dr Deborah Kingston who we first saw in July 2022 where has the time gone welcome back Deborah I said I hadn't realized how long 18 months where's it gone yeah I blinked and missed it but I think it's because you are in my world constantly because you're just so so kind to me Deborah on socials you're always so supportive and you just I don't know you get what I do and why I do it and yeah your your support is so so
这就是为什么我今天想邀请我们的嘉宾回来，我们之前在播客中讨论过创伤、多动症（ADHD）和阅读障碍。她就是黛博拉·金斯顿博士。所以我希望你会觉得这期节目非常有用。我期待着在节目后半部分与你交流。我想再次欢迎黛博拉·金斯顿博士回到播客，我们上次见到她是在2022年7月，时间过得真快。欢迎回来，黛博拉。我说我都没意识到已经过去18个月了，时间去哪儿了？是啊，我一眨眼就错过了。但我认为这是因为你一直在我身边，因为你在社交媒体上对我太好了，黛博拉，你总是那么支持我，而且你懂我在做什么，为什么要做这些。是的，你的支持真的非常
valued and so appreciated so thank you you're welcome I think I think as far as in the aspiring the next load of psychologists is so important that we have we try and get the right type of people into our profession though so the more you can get out there and the wider the reach I think that's only a good thing for for what we do in clinical psychology yeah thank you well it means a great deal so thank you so one of the things we were speaking about recently was kind of when as a psychologist or as aspiring psychologist or as anyone really that you kind of give your opinion or you kind of share your truth. And then it leads to negative reactions from people.
珍贵，非常感谢。不客气。我认为，对于下一批有志成为心理学家的人来说，我们努力让合适的人进入这个行业非常重要。所以，你能传播得越广，影响力越大，我认为这对我们临床心理学领域来说就是一件好事。是的，谢谢。这对我意义重大，谢谢。我们最近讨论的一件事是，作为一名心理学家、有志心理学家，或者任何人，当你发表意见或分享你的真相时，会引发人们的负面反应。
And it can feel a bit like what they call cancel culture, really. And it can lead to a really complex array of emotions for us, can't it? Yeah, it really can. And if you think about some of the work that we might even think about doing in schools, that when we go in and we're trying to explain how there's a child with neurodiversity and, you know, and it's been 40 years since I was really in the midst of school and being told I was too thick to learn. But actually going back in and thinking there should be way more change, way more issues. And when you start to put these things on the floor and explain what neurodiversity is and try and give a child's
这感觉有点像所谓的“取消文化”。这会给我们带来一系列复杂的心理情绪，不是吗？是的，确实如此。如果你想想我们在学校里可能做的一些工作，当我们进去试图解释一个患有神经多样性的孩子的情况时，距离我上学已经过去40年了，当时我被告知太笨而无法学习。但现在回去思考，应该有更多的改变，更多的问题。当你开始把这些事情摆在桌面上，解释什么是神经多样性，并试图给出一个孩子的
perspective to get men with a defense sometimes that cancels out what we want to say and be passionate about what we're saying because it's just taken so wrongly because there's a multitude of professionals out there that are kind of not wanting or willing to listen so you know that's that's a huge one across our profession whether it's be whether it's in cams whether it's in private practice whether it's just even sometimes what we say on social media platforms around um neurodivergence and neurodiversity so even just from a personal point of view hearing some of the comments that come out about people like you know even myself when i was out recently at a dinner you know and i thought was saying something quite important and for the person involved and then she's like oh wow you talk way too much though don't you
视角时，有时会遭到防御，这抵消了我们想要表达的内容和热情，因为我们的意思被完全误解了。因为外面有许多专业人士不愿意或不想倾听，所以这在我们的行业中是一个巨大的问题，无论是在儿童与青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）、私人诊所，还是有时我们在社交媒体平台上关于神经多样性的言论。所以，即使是从个人角度来看，听到一些关于像我这样的人的评论，比如最近我在参加晚宴时，我以为我在说一些对当事人很重要的事情，然后她说：“哦，哇，你话太多了，不是吗？”
and i immediately froze and kind of thought I need to shut up I need to stop talking and then I think she saw my reaction so I didn't mean it bad didn't mean it bad but you know but you do talk too much though gosh that's strong that's strong isn't it yeah and it was I don't think she meant it bad but and then I'm thinking well you know I've heard all these different things you've said, so I couldn't have been talking that much that I've not heard. And I just get passionate about delivering good advice, whether I'm on duty or off duty, because I don't think you can really separate the psychologist in this. I absolutely agree. You're kind of one room party.
我立刻僵住了，心想我需要闭嘴，我需要停止说话。然后我想她看到了我的反应，所以她可能不是恶意的，不是恶意的，但“你确实话太多了”。天哪，这很伤人，不是吗？是的，而且我不认为她是恶意的。但我心想，好吧，我听过你说的所有这些话，所以我不可能说得那么多以至于没听见。我只是对提供好的建议充满热情，无论我是在工作还是休息，因为我不认为你能真正把心理学家的身份从中剥离出来。我完全同意。你就像一个“单人派对”。
Yeah. agree you kind of want to party yeah and you know it's not being you know a dinner party psychologist to people that haven't consented but I just often find myself in very deep conversations with people whether that's in work or whether that's in pleasure whether that's by the football sidelines watching my children it's just it's just the frequency I operate on you know I can do a little bit of light banter and you know chit chat but that's not really the frequency that I resonate at best. And normally and it's the same and I think recently as well if you think about what's going on in Palestine and Israel there's a lot of heated divide going on even in our country and between us as professions where i think the media bias
是的，同意，你就像一个派对。而且你知道，这并不是说要成为那种在晚宴上未经同意就给别人做心理咨询的心理学家，但我经常发现自己与人进行非常深入的对话，无论是在工作中，还是在娱乐时，或者是在足球场边看我的孩子们踢球时。这只是我运作的频率。我可以进行一些轻松的调侃和闲聊，但那并不是我最能产生共鸣的频率。通常情况下，如果你想想最近巴勒斯坦和以色列发生的事情，即使在我们国家，以及在我们专业人士之间，也存在着很多激烈的对立。我认为媒体的偏见
and the lens that's coming out sometimes means that people just can't give an honest fear or feeling about what they're feeling and we have got clients that are coming into clinic saying this thing that's going on in the middle east i'm really worried about it you know and not feeling like you can say anything you know when things when things are bigger going on, or like, it's almost like, especially on LinkedIn at the minute, you know, somebody was on there the other week saying about that, if we're pro-Palestine, we must be anti-Jew. And I was thinking, actually, where is the humanity in that? You know, we've had colleagues in the EMDR world, from Palestine and Israel, that were once upon a time on shared training you know
以及所呈现的视角，有时意味着人们无法诚实地表达他们的恐惧或感受。我们有客户来到诊所说：“中东发生的这件事，我真的很担心。”他们觉得不能说任何话。当有更大的事情发生时，或者就像现在在LinkedIn上，有人上周说，如果我们支持巴勒斯坦，我们就一定是反犹太的。我当时在想，实际上，这里的人性在哪里？你知道，我们在EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）领域有来自巴勒斯坦和以色列的同事，他们曾经在共同的培训中，
and these people were coming together to make a better trauma world in that region who've now again been segregated and I don't feel like we as clinicians should be able to come down on one side or the other without having a real view of humanity and what it must be like for both sides and understand that and formulate that from a perspective when we put emotion in because we want to take a one-sided approach i think that's where we get shut down in this cancel culture like so one of the responses i said you know was it's really a shame that women children are being killed on both sides and the person came back really blunt with me and just said you've got it all
这些人在那个地区共同努力创造一个更好的创伤治疗世界，现在又被隔离开了。我不认为我们作为临床医生应该在不真正了解人性、不了解双方处境的情况下，就偏袒任何一方。我们应该从一个视角去理解和制定方案。当我们因为想要采取一边倒的立场而加入情绪时，我认为这就是我们在这种“取消文化”中被封杀的原因。比如，我回应说：“妇女和儿童在双方都被杀害，这真的很遗憾。”那个人非常生硬地回击我，说：“你完全错了。”
wrong you know and I can't remember the word the word vacates my mind what it's called when you're anti-jew because there was a word for it but I am so not you know anti-semitic anti-semitic that's it you want to do that little bit again you know my brain was no I'm happy my brain was just totally dyslexic I couldn't I had a brain fart it just wouldn't come out but you know and I think it's the same in anything you know I grew up in a in a world where there was a lot of poverty and a lot of oppression in working-class Scotland and people take a generational view of what oppression is from the English, powering down the Scots.
你知道，我不记得那个词了，那个词从我脑海中消失了，当你反犹太时叫什么？因为有一个专门的词。但我绝对不是反犹太主义者。反犹太主义，就是那个词。你想再重说一遍吗？你知道，我的大脑当时……不，我很高兴，我的大脑只是完全“阅读障碍”了，我大脑短路了，那个词就是出不来。但你知道，我认为任何事情都是一样的。我在一个充满贫困和压迫的苏格兰工人阶级世界中长大，人们对英国人压迫苏格兰人有着代际的看法。
You know, that's a very different world we're in now, but some people still hold that view and it's really personal to them. You know, so we don't just see this in the Middle East or in, you know, fractious parts of the world. You sometimes still see some of these conflicts and divides from generational histories and really kind of bearing down and who are we to kind of close down somebody's narrative without fully listening to it you know yeah really good points really good points with christmas coming up i think it's a really important point about
你知道，我们现在所处的世界已经非常不同了，但有些人仍然持有那种观点，这对他们来说非常个人化。所以，我们不仅在中东或世界动荡地区看到这种情况。你有时仍然会看到一些源于代际历史的冲突和分歧，这真的让人感到沉重。我们是谁，竟然在没有完全倾听的情况下就关闭了别人的叙述？你知道，是的，很好的观点，非常好的观点。随着圣诞节的临近，我认为这是一个非常重要的点，关于
how do we come together even look at families at christmas you know sometimes there's been some divide you know you might have grandparents and parents and children totally different generational stances and opinions how do all those voices get heard christmas can be one of the most stressful times for families you know or thanksgiving that they've just had in the states where you want to come together to put what this perfect view on where everybody gets on and sings from the same song sheet and a lot of time a lot of opinions get closed down in families and it can feel really invalidating those experiences and those differences and how do people manage that if we as psychologists
我们如何聚在一起。看看圣诞节的家庭，你知道，有时会有分歧。你可能有祖父母、父母和孩子，他们有着完全不同的代际立场和观点。所有这些声音如何被听到？圣诞节可能是家庭压力最大的时候之一，或者像他们在美国刚刚度过的感恩节，你想聚在一起，营造一种完美的氛围，每个人都相处融洽，唱着同一首歌。很多时候，家庭中许多意见被压制了，这会让人感到非常无效，那些经历和差异。如果作为心理学家，我们
aren't mirroring it even in sometimes in some of the work that we're doing out on social media yeah yeah really important and it's so easy to forget that not everybody exists in a in an ecosystem in their family or you know even in their wider family system that feels that they are seen as important, valid, special, you know, that they have a voice that's worth hearing. You know, even I know I was listening to something this morning on the radio of someone who is a gay man and had spoken about in the past, you know, it had been really, you know, taboo to be outwardly and openly gay, but he is supported in his family. But that's not always the case. And, you know,
没有在社交媒体上进行反思，人们该如何处理这些问题呢？是的，是的，非常重要。人们很容易忘记，并非每个人都生活在一个让他们感到被看见、被重视、被视为特别的家庭生态系统中，或者甚至在更广泛的家庭系统中，他们觉得自己的声音是值得被听到的。你知道，即使是我今天早上在广播里听到的，一个人是一名男同性恋者，他谈到过去，公开出柜是非常禁忌的，但他得到了家人的支持。但情况并非总是如此。而且，你知道，
with these festive celebrations, and not just Christmas, but whatever it is for whatever faith people follow, of course, when people do get together, sometimes we're asking people to to keep themselves in a box aren't we to make themselves smaller and I used to see this a lot with when I was working with people who were kind of second generation been raised probably by Bangladeshi parents and very different people to their friends than they were able to show to their wider family and sometimes even their immediate family and it was feeling like they were not living their authentic truths because of this fear of the council culture you know being told you're not a good enough daughter you're not a good enough person you're not good enough in your religion you're bringing
在这些节日庆祝活动中，不仅仅是圣诞节，无论人们信仰什么，当然，当人们聚在一起时，有时我们要求人们把自己关在一个盒子里，不是吗？让他们变得渺小。我以前在与那些第二代移民工作时经常看到这种情况，他们可能由孟加拉裔父母抚养长大，在朋友面前表现出的样子与在大家庭甚至核心家庭面前表现出的样子非常不同。他们感觉自己没有活出真实的自我，因为害怕“取消文化”，被告知“你不是一个好女儿”、“你不是一个好人”、“你在宗教上不够好”、“你在给自己甚至给我们带来耻辱”。这真是件大事，不是吗？
shame on yourself or even us it's a big deal isn't it it is an evening if you think some of i've got some um transgendered clients that have to dress not in the way they want to or be addressed in the way they want to at christmas because of the older generations that might be at the table and they've almost got to put a huge part of themselves in that box and turn up and be somebody they don't feel congruent with and that's such a sad position where they just don't feel that they can be good in themselves as themselves and i think that cancel culture just can really impact if we think about suicidal rates if we think about mental health rates at the minute the more we impact on that cancel culture where people just don't feel safe to say something i think what we do is we constantly put a part of them in a box and where does all the emotion go
确实如此。如果你想想，我有一些跨性别客户，因为桌上有长辈，他们在圣诞节不得不穿他们不想穿的衣服，或者不能以他们想要的方式被称呼。他们几乎必须把自己很大一部分关进那个盒子里，表现得像一个他们感觉不一致的人。这是一个多么悲伤的处境，他们只是觉得不能作为真实的自己而感到自在。我认为“取消文化”真的会产生影响。如果我们考虑自杀率，如果我们考虑目前的心理健康状况，我们越是助长那种让人觉得不敢说话的“取消文化”，我认为我们所做的就是不断地把他们的一部分关进盒子里。那么所有的情绪都去哪儿了？
when it's not been allowed to speak what happens when we suppress people from being their true authentic genuine selves when we say don't put your armor on stay bold what do we do to people when they're then faced with a high level of criticism and they're not wearing the armor because they're being true authentic selves it's going to hurt and penetrate into the core of them a lot bigger and a lot faster and a lot deeper so i think it's something we as psychologists we need to be thinking about in terms of cancel culture in terms of you know what's okay to be discussed or not discussed it's about what's true to the person and it's not always like it has to be said in a particular way that alienates other people but i think it has to be said in a way that is a truth that can be then explored curiously by other people yeah and I get I know you weren't
当人们不被允许说话时会发生什么？当我们压制人们展现真实、纯粹的自我时，当我们说“不要穿上你的盔甲，保持大胆”时，当他们面对高度批评而没有穿上盔甲时，我们对他们做了什么？因为他们展现的是真实的自我，这会更痛，更深地刺入他们的核心，更快、更深。所以我认为这是我们作为心理学家需要思考的问题，关于“取消文化”，关于什么可以讨论或不可以讨论。这关乎对个人来说什么是真实的，这并不意味着它必须以一种疏远他人的方式说出来，但我认为它必须以一种真相的方式说出来，然后可以被其他人好奇地探索。是的，我知道你不是
asking that question it was semi-rhetorical but I guess what I see when people have had to keep themselves in a box is there might be more anxiety because actually what I often see is that inverse relationship of when anger is not able to kind of be felt and anger anger doesn't always look like smashing stuff up does it sometimes anger just looks like asserting yourself you get more self-harm you get more anxiety and you get a dipping in self-worth and if that goes on for a long period of time it reduces your drive in every aspect of your life and you know before too long it feels like you haven't got people in your tribe that know you as you. And it feels very hard to find a way forward.
在问那个问题，那是一个半反问句。但我猜，当我看到人们不得不把自己关在盒子里时，我看到的是更多的焦虑。因为我经常看到的是一种反向关系：当愤怒无法被感知时——愤怒并不总是表现为砸东西，对吧？有时愤怒只是表现为坚持自我——你会得到更多的自残、更多的焦虑和自我价值感的下降。如果这种情况持续很长时间，它会降低你在生活各个方面的动力。你知道，没过多久，你就会觉得你的部落里没有真正了解你的人。而且很难找到前进的方向。
And it also exacerbates the sense of shame we feel about ourselves when we do comparisons with other people. No shame in itself can be toxic to the way the brain processes information, the way we relate to other people, even the way we interact within what should be our tribe. Because, you know, shame is meant to be one of the protective emotions that keeps us kind of regulated within the social norm, you know. Sometimes it just gets way too big. And also, if you're constantly invalidated, there's going to be a huge depth of sadness that nobody's seeing in, there's no connection, you know, and sometimes that depth of sadness is totally misunderstood, because what people see is its best buddy, anger, coming along to say, this isn't fair, hear me, and the more anger gets involved, the less people get heard, and then it becomes like a vicious
当我们与他人进行比较时，它也会加剧我们对自己感到的羞耻感。不，羞耻感本身对大脑处理信息的方式、我们与他人相处的方式，甚至是我们与部落互动的方式都是有毒的。因为，你知道，羞耻感本应是一种保护性情绪，让我们在社会规范内保持调节，你知道。有时它只是变得太大了。而且，如果你不断地被否定，就会有一种巨大的悲伤，没有人看到，没有连接，你知道。有时那种深层的悲伤被完全误解了，因为人们看到的是它最好的伙伴——愤怒，跳出来说：“这不公平，听我说。”愤怒参与得越多，人们被听到的就越少，然后它就变成了一个恶性
circle that we just keep going round and round. So it's about saying, how do we hear people without immediately jumping in on an emotional response? How do we understand what's going on for them? And how do we really hear the nuance of what they're saying behind the mask of anger or assertiveness, how do we get in and say, we see you for who you are and we are connecting? So I think whether, you know, you're just an aspiring psychologist or a psychologist or a mom or a sister or a brother or a friend, you know, this is like, this isn't just for us as professionals. This is for all people, because I think if we could kind of get that balance balance and I know it might be utopic of me to kind of want that but if we could get that there'd be less there'd be less discrimination in our everyday world yeah and you know sometimes I speak to clients who've got really good support systems around them who are able to have really
循环，我们只是不断地绕圈子。所以关键在于，我们如何在不立即陷入情绪反应的情况下倾听人们的声音？我们如何理解他们正在经历什么？我们如何真正听到他们在愤怒或自信的面具下所表达的细微差别？我们如何介入并说：“我们看到了真实的你，我们正在建立连接。”所以我认为，无论你是刚入行的心理学家，还是心理学家，或者是母亲、姐妹、兄弟或朋友，你知道，这不仅仅是针对我们专业人士的。这是针对所有人的，因为我认为如果我们能达到那种平衡——我知道我想要那种平衡可能有点乌托邦——但如果我们能做到，我们的日常世界中就会减少歧视。是的，你知道，有时我与那些拥有良好支持系统的客户交谈，他们能够进行
I don't know like I think of as Dawson's Creek style existential conversations without that fear of cancel culture. Or sometimes that's what we have together in therapy, actually. And I guess my plea to the world is there are people out there who will get you or who will help you explore yourself and your hard limits, your soft limits, you know, the things that you don't like about yourself, the things that maybe you've always felt proud about yourself, but feel like they're not things that other people think are good things. You know, there are people, there can be change. It's that, you know, adaptive belief that people can change, that suffering can reduce, that the distress can be neutralized and that people can be happy, people can thrive. I
我不知道，就像《恋爱时代》（Dawson's Creek）风格的那种存在主义对话，而没有那种对“取消文化”的恐惧。或者有时这正是我们在治疗中共同拥有的东西。我猜我对世界的恳求是：外面有人会理解你，或者会帮助你探索你自己，你的硬底线、软底线，你知道，那些你不喜欢自己的地方，那些你可能一直感到自豪，但觉得别人认为不是好东西的地方。你知道，有人在，改变是可能的。这就是那种适应性的信念：人们可以改变，痛苦可以减少，困扰可以被中和，人们可以快乐，人们可以茁壮成长。我
passionately believe that. And I've got kind of quite a lot of systemic leanings. And it can be really hard to do that in systems that are so stuck or so archaic or so old. One of the reasons I sort of stepped away from the NHS, it was all too slow. It was all too slow and a bit too archaic. But I know there are probably really forward-thinking NHS trusts and teams as well. Well, in a way, that was one of the reasons why I stepped away from the NHS
热切地相信这一点。我有一些系统性的倾向。但在那些如此僵化、陈旧或古老的系统中做到这一点真的很难。我离开英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的原因之一就是它太慢了。它太慢了，而且有点太陈旧了。但我知道可能也有非常有前瞻性的NHS信托基金和团队。嗯，在某种程度上，这也是我离开NHS的原因之一，
was this massive idea of cancel culture and not being able to kind of point out some of the negatives that were going on and how we could enhance patient care patient satisfaction therapeutic goals you know and when i tried to challenge this data as well i was met with huge resistance of pen pushers and adminis that were kind of like no no no and and i'm saying we're not delivering if we if we strip some some laborious bureaucratic processes out of clinical work we do more clinical work and therefore we see more people and we do better therapy or better nursing or better occupational therapy or whatever the profession was if we strip away a huge facet that's not actually clinical
就是这种关于“取消文化”的巨大观念，以及无法指出正在发生的一些负面问题，以及我们如何提高患者护理、患者满意度和治疗目标。你知道，当我试图挑战这些数据时，我遇到了官僚主义者和行政人员的巨大阻力，他们就像“不，不，不”。我说，如果我们剔除临床工作中一些繁琐的官僚程序，我们就能做更多的临床工作，因此我们能看到更多的人，我们能做更好的治疗、更好的护理或更好的职业治疗，或者无论是什么专业。如果我们剔除一个实际上不是临床的巨大方面
and process we'd get better work done and if also we strip out the millions of layers of management that want to suppress you we'd also have got more done so you know especially having managers that weren't psychologists felt like your role should be because of your pay banding, wasn't because of your intellect or your clinical skill, like they would do a medical doctor. All of a sudden, we were pigeoned as very different to medical doctors in the fact that we weren't seen as good enough as them. We weren't seen as bringing the big offerings of a medical doctor.
和流程，我们就能做得更好。如果我们也剔除那些想要压制你的数百万层管理人员，我们也能做得更多。所以，你知道，特别是那些不是心理学家的经理，他们觉得你的角色应该是因为你的薪资等级，而不是因为你的智力或临床技能，就像他们对待医学博士那样。突然之间，我们在被归类为与医学博士非常不同，事实上我们没有被视为和他们一样好。我们没有被视为能带来医学博士那样的大贡献。
But yet, we could transform somebody's life just as well, if not big offerings of a medical doctor but yet we could transform somebody's life just as well if not better than a medical doctor because we see the whole person now we can't treat a broken leg but we can treat the trauma that goes with the broken leg that might stop the leg from healing under the orthopedic consultant you know so there's stuff we can do and we should know our place and i think sometimes cancel culture comes in when people feel threatened you might know a little bit more you might be trying to change a system that the equilibrium is set as broke and you just may want to say do you know what let's change that equilibrium to
但实际上，我们能像医学博士一样，甚至比医学博士更好地改变一个人的生活，因为我们看到的是整个人。现在，我们不能治疗骨折的腿，但我们可以治疗伴随骨折腿的创伤，这可能会阻止腿在骨科顾问医生下愈合。所以，我们能做的事情很多，我们应该知道自己的位置。我认为有时当人们感到受到威胁时，“取消文化”就会出现。你可能知道得稍微多一点，你可能正试图改变一个已经设定为“坏”的平衡，你可能只是想说：“你知道吗，让我们把那个平衡改变为
something that might be working and the pushback on it both in the nhs and sometimes in the private sector not as much in the private sector because they have to fix it because private sector are a profit-led organisation and the NHS don't seem to have that same ethos yet. With the more foundation trusts there are, they're becoming their own mini businesses. So again, does the business drive the clinical work or does the clinical work drive the business?
可能有效的东西。”而在NHS和有时在私营部门的阻力——私营部门没那么多，因为他们必须修复它，因为私营部门是以利润为导向的组织，而NHS似乎还没有那种同样的理念。随着基金会信托的增多，它们正在成为自己的小型企业。所以，再次问一下，是业务驱动临床工作，还是临床工作驱动业务？
But again, we're not allowed those discussions. Yeah, I think this is probably particularly resonant for the people listening to this podcast that might well be aspiring psychologists so i know we do have qualified we do have people who are not yet even doing their psychology degree or might be thinking about doing a conversion masters you know we've got such a wide range but what we are likely to have is people that are highly driven that are highly motivated that are probably reading listening to these podcast episodes getting these current themes and so they are energized and certainly when I was an aspiring psychologist I had all this abundant energy and drive for change and this is why my
但同样，我们不允许进行这些讨论。是的，我认为这对于收听这个播客的人来说可能特别有共鸣，他们很可能是未来的心理学家。所以我知道我们有合格的心理学家，也有甚至还没开始读心理学学位或可能正在考虑攻读转换硕士学位的人。你知道，我们有如此广泛的受众，但我们很可能会有那些高度驱动、高度积极的人，他们可能正在阅读、收听这些播客剧集，获取这些当前的主题，所以他们充满了活力。当然，当我是一名有志心理学家时，我拥有所有这些丰富的精力和改变的动力。这就是为什么我的
superiors are saying god we, God, we love having assistants. We love having trainees because you've got all this energy. You've got all these ideas, but it can lead to burnout if you're not able to actually put that in place. So I guess this is my little shout out to our audience who are thinking, yes, this describes me, but I'm not able to make those changes and it you do risk burning out you risk just not voicing your ideas because you think well what's the point what's no difference will happen and that's the thing I think when people are looking at why psychologists leave in the NHS nobody really wants to hear the answer you want it to you know and even in private practice if you think about cancel culture and private practice is huge especially
上级说：“天哪，我们喜欢有助理。我们喜欢有实习生，因为你们有这么多精力。你们有这么多想法。”但如果你不能真正落实这些想法，它会导致倦怠。所以我猜这是我对我们听众的一个小呼吁，他们心想：“是的，这描述的就是我，但我无法做出那些改变。”你确实冒着倦怠的风险，你冒着因为觉得“反正没用，什么都不会改变”而不表达自己想法的风险。这就是我认为当人们审视为什么心理学家离开NHS时，没人真正想听答案的原因。你知道，甚至在私营部门，如果你想想“取消文化”，私营部门的情况非常严重，特别是
where i am we go to meetings as private psychologists it might be a safeguarding meeting it might be a meeting in the school and we are treated with suspicion and skepticism because we're not wearing an nh lanyard. We are treated as if we are not as good as our NHS counterparts. Yet we know that the level of CPD I do is phenomenal. I've got three supervisors, have no supervision in the NHS, I have to pay for it privately. You know, I have all this stuff. But when we go to these meetings our opinion our clinical opinion is cancelled because we don't wear an nhs lanyard and again that's something that's rippling through the private sector that i'm hoping the acp pick up on and try and get some marketing out there to
在我所在的地方，我们作为私人心理学家去开会，可能是保障会议，可能是学校里的会议，我们受到怀疑和怀疑，因为我们没有戴NHS的挂绳。我们被对待得好像我们不如NHS的同行。然而我们知道，我所做的CPD（持续专业发展）水平是惊人的。我有三个督导，在NHS里没有督导，我必须私下付费。你知道，我有所有这些东西。但当我们去这些会议时，我们的意见，我们的临床意见被取消了，因为我们没有戴NHS的挂绳。这再次是在私营部门中蔓延的事情，我希望ACP（心理咨询与心理治疗协会）能关注并尝试做一些营销，
actually say actually these clinical psychologists are bringing skills and and we're working in an ethically sustainable manner to ensure our cpd knowledge is is there because if we consider my i'm trauma specialist all i do is trauma every day long i'm an emdr consultant i'm really passionate about trauma you know and yet i went in to meet in an inpatient facility with a consultant clinical psychologist who hadn't done any training on the ICD-11's complex trauma diagnosis. Now, bearing in mind, I went in 2018 to the BPS in January for that training of what was coming, how it was going to inform practice. I go to this meeting in 2022 and they still are talking about the ICD-10 and trying to label the client that
真正说：“实际上，这些临床心理学家带来了技能，我们以一种道德可持续的方式工作，以确保我们的CPD知识在那里。”因为如果考虑到我是创伤专家，我每天做的都是创伤，我是EMDR顾问，我对创伤充满热情。你知道，然而我走进一个住院设施，与一位没有接受过ICD-11复杂创伤诊断培训的临床心理学顾问会面。现在，请记住，我在2018年1月去了BPS（英国心理学会）参加了关于即将发生的事情、它将如何指导实践的培训。我在2022年去参加这个会议，他们仍然在谈论ICD-10，并试图给客户贴上标签，
was clearly complex trauma from adult no childhood as potentially personality disordered because the person was challenging in the interpersonal dynamic when I laid out the formulation I was just closed down as private so again even when we bring the skills and knowledge that we get from the bps or the acp and the skills and training we've done from cpd currently in the uk there is a real big divide between private work and and nhs but again it probably doesn't help that our titles aren't um protected anybody can call themselves a psychologist so and i think that also comes in because how do you guard against that in this idea of council culture? You know, somebody's a trained counsellor. Celebrate you're a trained counsellor.
那显然是来自成年期，不，童年期的复杂创伤，因为当我在人际动态中提出方案时，因为那个人具有挑战性，我只是因为是私人的而被关闭了。所以，即使当我们带来从BPS或ACP获得的技能和知识，以及我们从CPD获得的技能和培训时，目前在英国，私人工作和NHS之间确实存在巨大的鸿沟。但同样，我们的头衔没有受到保护可能没有帮助，任何人都可以称自己为心理学家。所以我认为这也进来了，因为在这个“取消文化”的观念中，你如何防范这一点？你知道，某人是一名受过培训的咨询师。庆祝你是受过培训的咨询师。
Don't call yourself something you're not. You know, if you're a trained psychotherapist, call yourself a trained psychotherapist. You know, go with what you're training, your competencies say we're keen to do. But I think that also has an impact especially for you as aspiring psychologists you know how many we've seen some people who've done a degree get BPS status and then go and call themselves a psychologist as an undergraduate level and actually engage in some quite dangerous work so this should also be a shout out please it's about public protection so we're all shouting out not because we don't want to give
不要称自己为不是的东西。你知道，如果你是一名受过培训的心理治疗师，称自己为受过培训的心理治疗师。你知道，按照你的培训、你的能力所说的去做。但我认为这也有影响，特别是对于你们作为有志心理学家。你知道，我们看到多少人获得学位，获得BPS身份，然后以本科水平称自己为心理学家，并实际上从事一些相当危险的工作。所以这也应该是一个呼吁，请，这是关于公众保护。所以我们都在呼吁，不是因为我们不想给
you an opportunity and say don't do the work we're saying do it in an appropriately supervised manner so I know there's a bit of an extra rant but it does tie into that idea of cancel culture where you know it's almost like we shouldn't even be saying that because do we fear upsetting somebody I think it's all related though isn't it so sometimes I don't say stuff as a qualified psychologist that people are saying very very loud as unqualified psychologists and getting great traction and it's like I just don't know if it's safe for you to be saying that stuff or making those claims but I and I wouldn't say them even though I'm a qualified psychologist and maybe it is that professional regulatory body so when someone is for example
你们一个机会，说“不要做这项工作”，我们是在说“以适当监督的方式去做”。所以我知道这有点额外的咆哮，但它确实与“取消文化”的观念有关，你知道，这几乎就像我们甚至不应该说出来，因为我们害怕惹恼某人。我认为这一切都是相关的，不是吗？所以有时我作为一名合格的心理学家不说一些话，而那些不合格的心理学家却说得非常大声，并获得了巨大的关注。这就像，我只是不知道你那样说或提出那些主张是否安全。但我，即使我是合格的心理学家，我也不会说它们。也许这就是专业监管机构。所以当某人，例如，
using one of the protected is it nine different titles including practitioner psychologist but using derivatives of that you know forensic psychologist health psychologist etc etc one of those titles the protected titles which are by the hcpc we perhaps fear the cancel culture because we have that professional professional regulatory body whereas people that are not professionally qualified and regulated don't have that i remember once a renowned counselor calling herself a TV psychologist on this morning saying that OCD came about because of an infection and they just needed to take antibiotics. What? Yeah.
使用九种受保护头衔之一，包括执业心理学家，但使用其衍生词，你知道，法医心理学家、健康心理学家等等，那些受HCPC（健康与护理专业委员会）保护的头衔，我们也许害怕“取消文化”，因为我们有那个专业监管机构。而那些没有受过专业培训和监管的人却没有。我记得有一次，一位著名的咨询师在《今晨》（This Morning）节目上称自己为电视心理学家，说强迫症（OCD）是因为感染引起的，他们只需要服用抗生素。什么？是的。
And I'm like, hang on a minute. I think that got a wealth of complaints into this morning, you know, because again, and I think the media needs to play a role in this idea of putting the right professionals in the right place to get the right advice. And kind of really opening the door to what is going to safeguard and protect the public within mental health. Because it is such a lucrative industry for some people. We're seeing businesses pop up all over the place, trying to recruit psychologists to do some work, to make some money off the back of somebody else, but wanting them to do half a job.
我心想，等一下。我想那引起了对《今晨》的大量投诉，你知道，因为再次，我认为媒体需要在这个把合适的专业人士放在合适的位置以获得正确建议的观念中发挥作用。并真正打开大门，了解在心理健康领域内什么是保障和保护公众的。因为它对某些人来说是一个如此有利可图的行业。我们看到企业到处涌现，试图招募心理学家做一些工作，从别人的背后赚钱，但想让他们做一半的工作。
And again, people are doing it because it's driven by money or a fear that they won't get clients. And then they're penned into something that's actually quite dangerous for them. You know, these companies are editing their reports without letting them know. And lots of really spurious things going on in the market. So again, for us as professionals and being regulated, I think we've also got to watch who we're signing up with. Who are we working for? What are we doing? Who's protecting us?
同样，人们这样做是因为它是由金钱驱动的，或者害怕他们得不到客户。然后他们被关进了一些实际上对他们相当危险的事情中。你知道，这些公司在不让他们知道的情况下编辑他们的报告。市场上发生了很多非常虚假的事情。所以再次，对于我们作为专业人士并受到监管，我认为我们也必须注意我们与谁签约。我们为谁工作？我们在做什么？谁在保护我们？
And I think there's a big debate about assistant psychologists not getting support in certain organizations or not being supervised in certain organizations and I think organizations forget the role of as an assistant psychologist is to be an assistant to a psychologist you know it's in the definition of the title. So you can't employ an assistant psychologist without having a psychologist for them to assist. So these private organisations that want to put on their, like, registration for commission, you know, we've got an assistant psychologist,
我认为关于助理心理学家在某些组织中得不到支持或在某些组织中没有受到监督存在很大的争论。我认为组织忘记了助理心理学家的角色是作为心理学家的助理，你知道，它在头衔的定义中。所以你不能在没有心理学家协助的情况下雇用助理心理学家。所以这些私营组织想要在他们的，比如，委员会注册上写上，你知道，我们有一名助理心理学家，
we're doing all these psych conventions, we're doing X, Y and Z, but they can't. That assistant psychologist has no safeguarding. They're not protected because they don't have a psychologist to which to to monitor mentor and supervise them in the role so i think it's huge for what we're looking at the industry is what we're looking at not only for those professionals but for organizations kind of need to kind of be educated in what an assistant psychologist is or why we've got the layers in our training system and somebody coming out from a graduate degree psychology is the best
我们正在做所有这些心理学公约，我们正在做X、Y和Z，但他们不能。那名助理心理学家没有保障。他们没有受到保护，因为他们没有心理学家来监督、指导和督导他们的角色。所以我认为这对于我们正在审视的行业来说是巨大的，我们正在审视的不仅是那些专业人士，而且组织需要被教育什么是助理心理学家，或者为什么我们在培训系统中设置了这些层级。而一个刚从心理学研究生学位出来的人，是
field in the world for me to go study because i'm so passionate about it so but we want to be celebrating the roles a lot more and not putting people in jeopardy and under risk totally yeah i agree no it's it's it's it's all it's all relevant is that what's all related and i think even in you know nhs jobs now it's not just it's not just private industry you know assistant psychologist posts or what's called senior assistant psychologist posts going out at band five. They're really looking for someone to be able to run a service often. And that's just not, as you say, it's just not the function of an assistant psychologist. It's not safe. It's not ethical.
世界上最好的领域，让我去学习，因为我对此充满热情。所以，但我们想要更多地庆祝这些角色，而不是让人们处于危险和风险之中。完全同意，是的，我同意。不，这，这，这，这都是相关的，这就是“这一切都是相关的”。而且我认为即使在，你知道，现在的NHS工作中，这不仅仅是，不仅仅是私营行业，你知道，助理心理学家职位或所谓的资深助理心理学家职位以五级（Band 5）薪资发出。他们真的在寻找能够运行服务的人。而这正如你所说，这根本不是助理心理学家的功能。这不安全。这不道德。
And I think that's important. Once upon a time, all assistant psychologists were paid at band five. We were valued for the work coming off the back of a degree that was really, really hard. And, you know, like a nursing degree is the same length of time as a psychology degree. They can go straight into paid work, you know, and build up their layers in the NHS. We have to only sit at assistant psychologists, you know. And I think you should be paid your worth for what knowledge you're bringing. You have to be paid and monitored by a supervisor, because if you don't have that, what skills and experience are you actually teaching the assistant psychologist?
我认为这很重要。曾经有一段时间，所有助理心理学家的薪水都是五级。我们因在非常、非常困难的学位之后所做的工作而受到重视。而且，你知道，就像护理学位和心理学学位的时长一样。他们可以直接进入带薪工作，你知道，并在NHS中建立他们的层级。我们必须只能坐在助理心理学家的位置上，你知道。而且我认为你应该为你带来的知识获得应有的报酬。你必须由督导支付报酬并进行监督，因为如果你没有那个，你实际上在教助理心理学家什么技能和经验？
But again, this is management in the NHS, and we're almost cancelled out of our opinion because they think we're trying to safeguard a particular job when they're trying to deal with the dynamics of cost funding. So I understand where the dynamic comes from, but at the same point, you've got to do things clinically viable. I would say that a band five assistant feels like a hen's tooth, like it feels like a rare thing to see and to find
但话说回来，这是英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的管理问题，我们的意见几乎被无视了，因为他们认为我们是在试图保住某个特定的职位，而他们却在处理成本资金的动态问题。所以我理解这种动态的来源，但同时，你必须以临床可行的方式做事。我想说，五级助理就像凤毛麟角一样，感觉很难见到，也很难找到。
they tend to be four yeah yeah even in this area when I was an assistant it was band five and both my posts were band five um and then as years have gone on it's band four and then you have to do several assistant posts to get a band five but like you say they want them to be more autonomous have less supervision but there's a whole criteria of what keeps an assistant safe maybe that's another episode let's let's chat about that some more i'll bring you back on in a few months because i think that sounds like a really really interesting conversation but um if someone is spending spending time perhaps even over this Christmas holiday feeling like they fear being genuine to themselves or what they see as true or right what what can they do I think for me to protect themselves I guess in clinic one of the things I do with some of my young people that can't go be
他们往往是四级，是的，是的，即使在这个领域，当我还是助理时，那是五级，我的两个职位都是五级。嗯，随着时间的推移，现在变成了四级，你必须做几个助理职位才能达到五级。但正如你所说，他们希望助理更自主，减少监督，但关于如何保障助理的安全有一整套标准，也许那是另一集的内容，让我们再聊聊这个。几个月后我会再请你回来，因为我觉得那听起来是一个非常非常有趣的对话。但是，如果有人在圣诞假期期间感到无法做真实的自己，或者无法坚持他们认为正确的事情，他们能做什么呢？我想对我来说，为了保护自己，在临床工作中，我对我的一些年轻人所做的事情之一就是，如果他们不能去……
their true authentic genuine selves at christmas and they notice the upset about it we kind of do like a resourcing strategy where we kind of get them to know what their values are in that what are your values and who you are what your values that you're bringing what element can you bring to that christmas day meal how long are you going to spend there what other things are you going to do that day that say that you can tap into those values and that way you might not be able to and it's not fair that you're not able to but what we don't want to do is create too much conflict with other people so it is very challenging in a way if this is still being recorded as it is that frozen expression
在圣诞节做真实的、纯粹的自己，并且他们注意到了因此而产生的苦恼，我们通常会采取一种资源策略，让他们了解自己的价值观是什么。你的价值观是什么？你是谁？你带来了什么价值观？你能在圣诞晚餐中贡献什么元素？你要在那里待多久？那天你还要做些什么来体现这些价值观？这样你可能无法做到（完全做自己），而且你无法做到这一点是不公平的，但我们不想与他人制造太多冲突。所以，如果这还在录制中，这种僵住的表情确实非常具有挑战性。
that you see with Dr Marianne Trent if we could have done that and role played that that's a lot of the faces that people get when they sit around the table and they can't be their authentic self that they freeze out they bone out they can't connect they don't know what to do and sometimes that's when they're faced with that it's really really difficult because if you were sat around the christmas table we had a problem with i don't i wasn't there my internet when you read it when you hear it back i did a lovely little thing about your frozen face is sometimes what we get when people freeze you out around the table when you can't be your authentic self and could you imagine how that would feel if you were talking in that dialogue with somebody that's not actually there so I did a little thing just in case just because I could see the timer going and I thought I'm
你和Marianne Trent博士看到的那个表情，如果我们能做到这一点并进行角色扮演，那就是人们坐在桌子旁无法做真实的自己时所表现出的许多面孔。他们僵住了，他们退缩了，他们无法建立联系，他们不知道该怎么办。有时当他们面对这种情况时，真的非常非常困难。因为如果你坐在圣诞餐桌旁，我们遇到了一个问题，我不知道，我当时不在那里，我的互联网……当你回听的时候，我做了一件可爱的小事，关于你僵住的脸，有时当你在餐桌旁无法做真实的自己时，人们会把你拒之门外。你能想象如果你在和那个实际上并不在那里的人对话，那会是什么感觉吗？所以我做了一点小事，以防万一，因为我可以看到计时器在走，我想……
going to do something I'm delighted you were still there because I thought that the whole platform would gone down and I thought it had lost all our recording so far and I was like but it's been really good so I'm back everybody so I'm back I didn't pause but then I thought oh I can I could use this to what I was saying about how people deal with that idea of going and not being able to be your true authentic self because really what you're looking at is that idea that somebody's not fully with you you know and actually just being a part of yourself in that session in that in that from that christmas dinner table or around the festive meal where you know people can't hear you in the way you need them to so you're listening she's not a beginner at this is she folks she's i just she's a pro
我很高兴你还在那里，因为我以为整个平台都崩溃了，我以为我们所有的录音都丢失了，我当时想……但这真的很棒。所以我回来了，大家好，我回来了。我没有暂停，但我当时想，哦，我可以利用这一点，谈谈我刚才说的关于人们如何处理那种无法做真实的自己的想法。因为你真正看到的是，有人并没有完全和你在一起。你知道，实际上在那个环节中，或者在圣诞晚餐桌旁，或者在节日聚餐时，人们无法以你需要的方式倾听你，所以你在倾听。她不是新手，对吧，伙计们？她是个专业人士。
i love that thank you was i doing something really unattractive in my mid-pause game? No, you just looked slightly sad. So I thought it just captured you. That's perfect. And I actually said if we'd set that up, that you could have done that. Then that's what people are faced with. OK. Oh, absolutely beautiful. Absolutely beautiful. I hope that you are going to be surrounded this Christmas and this new year with people that make you feel really good Debra oh I am and I've got my my grandson who's coming here who is just turned one and my daughter and it's just our little family
我喜欢这个，谢谢。我在暂停期间做了什么非常不吸引人的事情吗？不，你只是看起来有点悲伤。所以我认为这正好捕捉到了你。太完美了。我实际上说过，如果我们预先设定好，你本可以做到这一点。这就是人们所面临的情况。好的。哦，绝对美丽。绝对美丽。我希望这个圣诞节和新年，你会被那些让你感觉非常好的人包围。Debra，哦，我是，我孙子要来这里，他刚满一岁，还有我女儿，这只是我们的小家庭。
for Christmas um because then anybody can say anything and be anything um and then I'm off to Scotland for new year it's my spiritual home and I'm going to the north of Scotland to be with friends and who make me really really happy and then I get to celebrate with my own family for my nephew's 21st straight after the new year and then it's back into a busy clinic oh well it sounds marvelous and thank you so much for sharing your your wonderful view on all of this and compassionate and balanced and just a really safe space as ever wishing you and your family and all of our listeners of course a really peaceful december into january whatever that looks like for them whether that looks like christmas or whether it just looks like a bit
过圣诞节，嗯，因为那样任何人都可以说任何话，做任何事。然后新年我要去苏格兰，那是我的精神家园。我要去苏格兰北部和那些让我非常非常开心的朋友在一起。然后我可以在新年过后立即为我侄子的21岁生日和我的家人一起庆祝，然后就回到繁忙的诊所了。哦，听起来太棒了，非常感谢你分享你对这一切的美好见解，既富有同情心又平衡，而且一如既往地提供了一个非常安全的空间。祝你和你的家人以及我们所有的听众，当然，度过一个非常宁静的十二月到一月，无论这对他们来说意味着什么，无论这意味着圣诞节，还是仅仅意味着一点……
of time off from the hustle to to kind of decompress and you know be the hopefully be the best you can be I think it just should be a time forget that it's Christmas we have multi-faiths in our profession it should just be a time we connect with loved ones where possible and where not possible we connect with other people that are like family that may not be blood that allow us to feel that we're connected because being alone at any time of the year except in the depth of the winter is much much harder so I think it's just about being connected and looking after yourself. Thank you so much what lovely lovely advice to end on thank you for your time and yeah we'll get you back on to just to really kind of take a look at what, I guess, what an optimum gold standard assistant psychologist role should and could look like. So
从忙碌中抽出时间来放松一下，你知道，希望成为最好的自己。我认为这应该是一个时间，忘记它是圣诞节，我们的职业中有多种信仰，它应该只是一个我们尽可能与亲人联系的时间，如果不能，我们就与像家人一样的人联系，即使没有血缘关系，也能让我们感到联系。因为在一年中的任何时候，除了深冬，感到孤独都更难。所以我认为这只是关于保持联系和照顾好自己。非常感谢，多么可爱、可爱的建议，以这个结束。谢谢你的时间，是的，我们会请你回来，真正地看看，我想，一个最佳的黄金标准助理心理学家角色应该是什么样子的。所以……
you and I can both perhaps have a little bit of a play in the background. And perhaps this is an example for people to even anonymously share stuff about stuff that doesn't feel that safe. Or, you know, the other way around, if you've got stuff that you't feel that safe or you know the other way around if you've got stuff that you feel is really going well for you as an assistant do send that in to me um and deborah and i can take a look at that and kind of weave that into the episode as well so wishing you a wonderful um christmas and new year um and thank you very much for your time deborah you're welcome welcome back along gosh how absolutely wonderful to speak about all of these things with deborah you're welcome welcome back along gosh how absolutely wonderful to speak about all of these things with deborah um i'm recording this straight after i saw her um and so i'm hoping
你和我或许可以在后台一起探讨一下。也许这是一个例子，让人们甚至可以匿名分享一些感觉不那么安全的事情。或者，你知道，反过来，如果你有一些作为助理感觉进展非常顺利的事情，请发送给我，嗯，Debra和我可以看看，并将其编入剧集中。所以祝你有一个美好的圣诞节和新年，嗯，非常感谢你的时间，Debra。不客气，欢迎回来。天哪，和Debra谈论所有这些事情真是太棒了。嗯，我是在见到她之后立即录制这段话的，所以我希望……
that the slight internet glitch i had meant that all of the content was um yeah was recorded and and is going to work but we're going to leave that little bit of glitch in for you so that you can see that, you know, we're all right with not being perfectionistic. If you are listening to this on Christmas Day, then wishing you a wonderful Christmas Day and Christmas period. But of course, you might be listening to it on Christmas Day and not celebrate Christmas. And that is OK, too. But wherever you are in the world I hope that you are feeling safe I hope that you are warm and I hope that you are being kind to yourself thank you so much for being part of my world if you'd like to come and follow me on socials
我遇到的轻微互联网故障意味着所有的内容都，嗯，是的，都被录制下来了，并且会起作用。但我们会把那一点点故障留给你，这样你就可以看到，你知道，我们没必要追求完美。如果你是在圣诞节当天收听这个节目，那么祝你有一个美好的圣诞节和圣诞假期。但当然，你可能是在圣诞节当天收听，但不庆祝圣诞节。那也没关系。但无论你在世界的哪个角落，我希望你感到安全，我希望你感到温暖，我希望你善待自己。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你想在社交媒体上关注我……
please do I'm Dr Marianne Trent everywhere if you are watching ons please do i'm dr marianne trent everywhere um if you are watching on youtube please do like and subscribe and share this content with people that you think might find it helpful come along to the aspiring psychologist community group on facebook um yeah thank you for being such an important part of my world, giving me a reason to record podcast episodes all year long. I look forward to bringing you more brilliant, fresh content. Please do feel free to pitch your podcast episodes to me. Thank you for being such loyal listeners and watchers. And I will see you very soon. The next episode will be along 6am on Monday.
请务必关注，我到处都是Dr Marianne Trent。如果你是在YouTube上观看，请务必点赞、订阅并与你认为可能会觉得有帮助的人分享这些内容。加入Facebook上的Aspiring Psychologist社区小组。嗯，是的，谢谢你成为我世界中如此重要的一部分，让我全年都有理由录制播客剧集。我期待着为你带来更多精彩、新鲜的内容。请随时向我推荐你的播客主题。感谢你们成为如此忠实的听众和观众。我们很快就会再见。下一集将在周一早上6点播出。
Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll side to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a
保重。那么让这个播客成为你的指南，让你在成为合格心理学家的道路上前进。这是与Marianne博士一起的Aspiring Psychologist。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名……
clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。